[Musik]
ich bin heute hier in kärnten ruhe wir
ja eine ganz schwierige situation
vorgefunden haben in den letzten tagen
mit hochwasser wie man hinter mir auch
noch sehen kann wo wir das bundesheer
großartige arbeit geleistet hat wir mit
5800 mannstunden und aktuell mit 130
soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz
stehen um der bevölkerung zu helfen und
das zeigt uns auch dieser einsatz wie
notwendig und wichtig investitionen in
das richtige gerät sind und da möchte
ich noch einmal die hubschrauber auch
hier ansprechen die hier auch großartige
arbeit geleistet haben und ohne diese
hubschrauber auch hier diese hilfe nicht
möglich gewesen wäre